[Musique]
2014 à gleneagles en écosse je les
choisis aussi parce qu'il y avait du
buisson et moi j'avais jamais vu une
ryder cup avec un français de danger
toucher le trophée thomas levet mais je
n'ai jamais vu jouer en ryder cup donc
avec victor c'était quand même super
sympa et on pourra gagner il ya eu
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de frissons
des chip rentrer tous les côtés c'était
l'époque avec patrick reed jordan spis
donc c'était un peu plus près de ma
génération aussi donc c'était ça qui
était sympa et oui et donc les gars
aient joué avec tellement de fierté pour
leur pays ou leur continent ça c'est
dans chaque édition un driver cup là où
il ya le plus de pression à les arènes
le plus rempli et au final c'est là
qu'on a les scénarios les plus
dramatiques
et donc là c'est là cette édition était
plus facilement gagnée par les européens
que deux ans auparavant mais je me
rappelle du dernier coup de jamie
donaldson si je me trompe pas quelqu'un
car les mythes je suivais pas du tout et
qu'il a pendant l'arrêt leur comme
j'étais quasiment d'une fan en fait qui
avait fait un coup de fer là
m du drapeau au sol
pour gagner la raideur il avait continué
les simples ensuite il y avait riddla
qui avait fait son shoot comme ça au
public pour les taquiner puis deux ans
après du coup il y avait une petite
réplique de maccarone mais oui c'est
c'est génial c'est unique comme
expérience
[Musique]